i nearly died and i'm terrified
of going back to where we were i met
sahel four months ago
he'd spent more than a month in an
induced coma he woke to find
he had survived covid19 but the disease
had killed his mum
are you holding up hold on he tells me
the government failed to protect the
country before and unless restrictions
are imposed
he's terrified the same thing will
happen again
if they had got it right from the very
beginning
we wouldn't have ended up at this stage
they still need to introduce uh
stricter measures you know even though
i'm in
the recovery stages of you know
kovin 19 you know there's nothing saying
that you know i can't contract it again
you know
and that is what scares me some of the
country's leading scientists agree with
sahel professor john edmonds
is a member of sage the scientific panel
that advises the government
he says the new measures have not gone
far
enough i think politicians are timid so
they're going to wait for it to get bad
before they take the the necessary
action
the government has announced some
measures
i'm not sure they're going to be
sufficient to slow the growth
significantly an effective testing
system was supposed to prevent any need
for further lockdowns
and until we have one more restrictions
it's argued
must be imposed the clever thing to do
now is to act firmly and quickly
any delay in implementing them will cost
more cases and perhaps go further with
potentially closing the pubs and
reducing the level 6 down to a smaller
number
but the scientific community is
polarized
something lockdowns are simply not a
sustainable long-term solution
it would be perfectly reasonable to er
on the side of caution
if that erring didn't come with some
really rather extraordinary costs
to the rest of the population who are
not vulnerable
so unfortunately because the cost of
lockdown is so high
we have to consider the probability of
this worst case scenario
when sahel was discharged from hospital
he and the rest of the country
would have hoped the worst was behind us
but now with a possible second surge
the government faces one of its greatest
challenges
balancing lives with livelihoods ashish
joshi skyness